the new shul started in 1999 and as the
founding rabbi I along with many of our
founding families who are still with us
looked around Manhattan and just thought
that there really wasn't a synagogue out
there for them that they wanted to
belong to and for me that I wanted to
lead they really spoke to our needs
which may sound surprising in a place
with as many Jewish residences New York
City but there really wasn't anything
out there that we felt was the right fit
for either of us and I think what makes
us interesting and maybe a little unique
is a we have tried to follow the mantra
of a great Hasidic mystic nachman of
breslov who says I come to show you a
new way that is ancient so if you think
about the word radical the the real
meaning of the word radical means a
return to the roots etymologically so
what we've really tried to do over the
last decade or so with initial is create
the this hybrid community where on one
level some of what we do is very
out-of-the-box and very edgy
particularly holiday events which
sometimes feel more like guerrilla
theater because we take them to the
streets often then a than a conventional
synagogue experience but other times you
come and it feels like a warm very
informal but kind of traditional
experience and so we've really tried to
blend the old with the new the
innovative with the the historic and and
the the he inherited and you know so
that's a I think be is we are not afraid
of taking risks and that includes the
risk of failure and I think too many
spiritual communities are afraid of
taking risks and that's a mark of
cowardice not not not wisdom I think
that like an entrepreneur most of the
ones that I've spoken to have failed 10
times before they get that one you know
great success and I would say in terms
of religious ritual or holiday events or
any other aspect of
life we have had great successes over
the years but we've also had flops and I
think that that's fine so I think that's
another important thing that defines the
new Schewel this is that we're willing
to take chances and too few communities
are willing to go there
because so many of our members come from
the arts community and that that's
changed a little bit you know Greenwich
Village is where we draw our our core
membership it but since nine eleven
Greenwich Village has changed lot too so
it still attracts a certain kind of
person with a very creative sensibility
but it's certainly not the the same
place it was in the 20s or 30s or or 50s
you know and people like like Jackson
Pollock were running around so I think
that one of the things we've realized is
that it's very hard to put on a kind and
many of our members coming from the
theater community to kind of put on a
religious ritual that feels like a
production and yet also feels
religiously authentic it's very tricky
and unless you have professionals who
are doing it it sometimes cannot be as
effective as it might be so I would say
in the area of holidays which is where
we tend to be our most theatrical and I
think there is a lot of overlap between
theater and religion and I think a lot
of theater has its roots in religion all
you have to do is look back at ancient
Greek theater and much of it most of it
is drawn from from religious rituals to
see that this crossover is very old and
very strong but for example on Hanukkah
we have created over the years this kind
of abstract light sculpture instead of a
traditional Hanukkah menorah menorah and
have gone to Washington Square Park and
interwoven traditional and contemporary
and music and liturgy and in poetry and
it's been a real success for us but
again you know when you try to do more
full blown kinds of religious rituals in
theatrical ways you have to strike that
right balance between authenticity and
the kind of theatricality that I think
is not just stick but something that
makes the experience multi-sensory and
and really powerful for people and
that's hard when you're dealing with
volunteers and lay people who aren't
trained in this area
I don't want to get in trouble here you
know I served a couple of years at a
very large suburban congregation as the
assistant rabbi and I was a very very
different experience than being the
founding rabbi of the new xual partly
because I've been able to basically do
whatever I wanted as the founding rabbi
have a brand new community of course in
in partnership with my leadership Miley
leadership so you've got just a very
surface difference but it's very
important one you know I feel like the
shackles were removed from me and I
could be free to be the kind of rabbi I
wanted to be and help create the kind of
community that we all wanted I think
when i was working as an assistant rabbi
at a large suburban synagogue i went
into work in a jacket and tie every day
which is not who i am but i felt that
that was the culture of that community i
really had to do that i was the very
first rabbi in that particular community
to wear a kippah no cap and I don't wear
one on the street just like now but I
always wear one for worship services and
I had to actually fight to have this
done and because that wasn't part of
their culture came from a very classical
kind of reform judaism that really
shined a lot of ritual since then
there's been a much more renewed
openness to ritual in in the reform
movement within Judaism but at the new
Schewel I'm free to do whatever I want
and so I have in some ways been more
informal and contemporary and I lead
services and have led ritual and holiday
events in jeans or in flannel shirts and
in sneakers if that's what makes me
comfortable partly because that's who I
am and partly because it makes other
people feel more comfortable and that's
what I want on the other hand I've worn
very traditional garments that more
liberal rabbis like me almost never
aware for example during the days of awe
I I always were sort of a funky version
of a kittle it's this white garment
that to this day is worn almost
exclusively by Orthodox or ultra
Orthodox men and it's an outward
expression of of purity and openness the
idea that during the ten days of
repentance we literally we well not
literally we we figuratively and
metaphorically stand naked and exposed
before before God and as I write in the
challenge of the soul to me whenever I
put on that kittle during the days of
awe it it reminds me exactly of putting
on the white key that I that I put on
whenever I step on to the wooden floor
of a dojo to engage in martial arts
training so the parallels there are
pretty striking as well the garment
looks virtually identical except in
martial arts training I put on a black
belt and with my congregation the gult
is white